[Musique]
au détour d'un coup de pinceau une
sculpture germain roesz mais ni les
formes les pigments et différentes
techniques des arts plastiques l'artiste
fait danser la couleur quand j'ai une
couleur rouge par exemple et que je veux
un bleu je suis obligé de passer à
partir de la couleur rouge partout les
par une dizaine de couleurs pour arriver
aux bleus et je les pose sur la toile et
donc vous avez une espèce de continuité
coloré une chose commune commun comme
une ligne
continue comme ça qui se déroule dans la
dans la peinture dans chaque peinture
avec sa peinture il veut parler de
jubilation de plaisir immense germain
roesz fait de l'art monumental des
pièces de près de quatre mètres de haut
pensée pour le conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux
quand je suis venu voir le lieu il ya
plusieurs mois j'ai pris les mesures et
je tenais à le modifier par la taille
des pièces de toutes ces pièces ont été
peintes en début d'année pour saint
quentin
savarese avait pas d'autres destinations
germain race conjugue son art à la
poésie une pensée qui se poursuit à la
médiathèque du canal avec une sélection
d'ouvragés jusqu'au 21 avril
[Musique]